this week on quadriga anti-migrant
violence mob rule in Saxony anti-migrant
attacks have grown frequent in the
German state last week an angry mob
chanted go home go home as refugees
arrived in the small town of Klaus Nets
just a short while later an arson attack
and bouncing also in Saxon aid as a
planned refugee shelter burned onlookers
cheered and tried to block the work of
the fire service there have already been
more than 100 attacks on refugees so far
this year in Germany Saxony is one of
the key flash points why is there such a
potential for violence in German society
and how can the racist mob be stopped
coming to you from Berlin quad Riga the
international debate your host this week
Melinda crane
hello and welcome is that potential for
violence unique to Saxony or is it a
problem in Germany as a whole that's one
of the things we want to talk about on
quadriga today with three people who are
following events in Saxony very closely
it's a pleasure to welcome my colleague
Fabian from Denmark he is DWS
correspondent for domestic politics and
security matters he just came back from
Saxony where he reported on the latest
incidents and he says the government in
Saxony still hasn't understood that the
fight against xenophobic violence is a
major task and it needs a proper plan
and it's a pleasure to welcome Alan
Posner back to the show he's a
commentator for the German newspaper
developed he says you can find stupid
people anywhere in Europe the really
dangerous people are the intellectuals
who use the mob for their own purposes
and finally we're happy to welcome makan
and Miss kina he's an expert for
migration and diversity at the Heinrich
Grove foundation here in Berlin he says
the mainstream politicians talk of a
flood of refugees of upper limits and
Islamization all of that is fuel on the
fire of right-wing extremism phobia
phony mark take us to Saxony if you
would what is behind the violence there
who is this mob it's difficult to say
really I mean at the moment there are
still investigation who who exactly is
behind this those incidents but it
is already pretty to the core of our
discussion I think because there's a
whole scale of explanations who these
people are it reaches from extremist
right-wing radicalized almost terrorist
achill people towards angry normal
citizens and somewhere in between these
polls you have to search for those
people what we do know is it was about
hundred people that surrounded this bus
and there was a smaller group in bouts
and in Boston for example where the
refugee shelter burned you had before
third more than thirty anti-refugee
initiatives so it's pretty likely that
people come from this background but you
don't know exactly who those offenders
were and why saxony what's wrong with
saxony it has been the site of 20% of
all xenophobic attacks over the past
year although in fact it's only taking
5% of the refugees so what's going on
yeah it's interesting really when you
talk to people and I talk to many people
there to scientists to politicians to
ordinary people on the street you get a
whole bunch of explanations and some of
the explanations they can't be valid
because they would apply to other states
other parts of Germany too so there has
to be a certain problem in Saxony
particular in Saxony I'm sure we will
talk about that later but yeah it's a
mixture I suppose of economical lack of
economic prospects of a dissatisfaction
with the politics in general there's a
certain national regional pride there so
there's a very interesting mix and bad
mix and there's also for a long time a
right-wing movement that is pretty
strong stronger than in other parts of
Germany and Posner the former president
of the Bundestag volcán tearsa who
himself is from East Germany said very
recently that he thinks people there are
quote more receptive to dehumanizing
messages is this a case of incomplete
socialization 26 years after the wall
fell or why the East well yes I mean has
too
with communism I mean if you imagine I
mean these can all of these eastern
parts of Germany were communism we have
a similar problem in Poland singer
phobia rabid nationalism we have similar
problem in Hungaria in most of Eastern
Europe it has to do with the fact that
there was no Democrat or virginal
democratic tradition until 1989 then
suddenly the wall comes down these
people are incorporated into the West
but there was no real dealing with the
question of what is communism what's bad
about communism what's also bad about
certain reactions to communism because
they had a right wing problem in Saxony
even under communist rule and if they
didn't talk about it so people you know
there was a sort of idea in the West
that give the people jobs give the
people social security and so on its own
son and there some slowly grow into
democracy and of course with the
majority this is - this is true but for
a minority I think about 20% this hasn't
happened and this is the bedrock on
which left-wing and right-wing extremism
is building Makonnen miss Dina we've
talked about it frequently in the past
the fact that there's a lot of racism in
places where there is scarcely any
diversity how do you account for that
well it shows that there's no actually
empirical explanation what's going on I
mean if we look into the situation in
Saxony interest and etc the number of
refugees the number of Muslims etc etc
it's far below the average in in Germany
in every German city like 10 times more
immigrants refugees and Muslims etc so
this is an ideological problem so it's
not the issue of quantity it's not the
numbers so there's no empirical
explanation for that it's not the issue
of jobs and process in Dresden is doing
quite well Dresden is doing much better
than many other Western Germany cities
so even the economical and the social
economic situation doesn't apply very
much to that so we have an ideological
problem and that's
why I think this has been neglected for
quite a long time that there is indeed a
social problem to deal with to tackle
with xenophobia to deal with racism and
so on so many politicians were pretty
much concerned or even the the site was
very much concerned with his own image
rather than to tackle the issues which
are at hand I want to come back to the
politicians role just a moment but
Fabian Funderburk you mentioned that
this is a region where there's a strong
sense of regional identity a sense of
self-confidence
some people compared it even to Bavaria
and say that the Saxons are very proud
of their state how does that fit into
all of this yeah I mean it's a very old
state it has a short name sexes and it's
not like one of those mingled states
like Rhineland Files or Saxon unmaking
before it's Saxony it's a long tradition
and it also defines itself via a strong
opposition for example to Prussia in the
past to Berlin so the sex and the people
from sex and he always had the sense we
are special we are maybe somehow even
superior and I believe that that they
think that wasn't really recognized by
the rest of Germany so the rest of
Germany hasn't recognized that the
Saxons are so great and I mean they
believed that there was too much imposed
on them I mean they had politicians
exported to Saxony from the West they
had ideas coming to Saxony but if you
believe that we are the best we can deal
with our problems on ourselves and you
keep on getting ideas from the outside
maybe that has led to a reaction that
they said all right now we isolate
ourselves we reject everything and
everyone that comes from the outside and
we are ourselves and that's enough and
we don't want anything from the outside
economist kina I also had the feeling
when I heard some of the voices of
people in Saxony that they were saying
we're just concerned citizens and
actually we're simply taking the lead
and speaking up and saying what other
people are too timid to say do you think
it's right to talk about this as largely
a problem of Saxony or is there in fact
a great deal of potential for xenophobic
violence elsewhere
Germany as well are they speaking for
others in other parts of the country
this is a very difficult question well
in general I don't think Dresden is the
voice of Germany I don't believe in that
nonetheless I don't even think on the
other side that Tristan is just a unique
example in in Germany so well it is
there is a movement let's say that it's
a movement which is which is poisoning
the the climate the climate of
multiculturalism the climate of
immigrant immigration and the issue of
social cohesion etc and this is not I'm
not sure whether this is the situation
interest and ease represents the the
atmosphere and other cities I don't
think because there were similar
movements in in Moline like the big
movement pegida which is a patriotic
europeans turn against Islamization this
is abbreviated pegida
and there were some others who copied
this kind of movement pegida in in
berlin and leggy des in leipzig etc etc
and in none of those cities has it been
successful as interesting so there may
be some special explanations for Saxony
I cannot tell because there is no
empirical explanation for me why Dresden
because succs only has a good
educational system Saxony has and
Dresden and the area of stressin is
successful in in attracting investors
etc so there are quite good
preconditions for a successful society
nonetheless there is some animosity
against everybody who is not from within
Saxony or maybe from Dresden impose no
we have talked a lot on this program
before about pegida the large dresden
based movement of so-called patriotic
europeans against the islamization of
germany and europe you say in
opening statement today that
intellectuals are inciting violence we
did of course hear a lot of speeches at
pegida rallies that were very very fiery
there were gallows there were calls - in
a veiled references to concentration
camps and so on is that the incitement
that you're talking about and if so does
it still fall under the category of free
speech or should authorities be have
long since taken measures to stop it
well actually you know this sort of
loose talk incitement to violence isn't
what I'm talking about there has been
since reunification in Germany an
intellectual movement that once Germany
to be something other than a Western
democracy and these are intellectuals
mostly by the way from the West people
like that kubacheck people like york el
asesor i mean you can name names they
they have their own newspapers newspaper
called the unified young freedom and
since 1989
they've been against democracy they've
been looking for a cause to pin their
hopes on so first it was we want to
revise german history but we don't talk
them so much about the holocaust german
war guilt and so on then it was we were
against homosexual married
now if they pinned onto this one and
they're using this there they're using
the people who demonstrate they're using
people like pegida
for their own cause that's the point so
and and you can't you know i mean these
are people who have intellectual ideas
and you have to discuss those ideas and
that they don't boil down to gallows i'm
they do at the very end you have to you
know cuz in the end they want to get rid
of democracy but you have to take these
people intellectually series you know
what a condescend to them and say oh
they haven't had a job chance to haven't
that this deal no these are
intellectuals with a mission but i think
not just intellectual they also they
have a really strong language
maybe the intellectual side remains
pretty well series or they claim to be
intellectuals that have to be treated
well but most of those discourses they
take place in the internet and whenever
you look at the comments below you find
like
strongest language and it's also a
question I'm sure or I know that
security circles are really concerned by
this radicalization of language because
they fear that that might lead to
radicalization of action as well and we
are at this stage where language has
been radicalized a lot and in the
internet incumbents you can find really
really hate speech more and more and
also from people that used to be maybe
in the center of society in the middle
of society but have radicalized their
language in a way which is very new
interestingly enough if you talk about
the radicalization of language it's
interesting to look at the slogan that
is being shouted at those rallies by
pegida the protests have co-opted the
slogan that was used by East Germans
when they took to the streets to bring
the wall down namely via zine does
Foulke we are the people
what was once a call of courage has been
a cop become a call of exclusion let's
take a look
we are the people chant members at the
pegida movement on the streets of
Dresden every Monday the same cry that
went up before East Germany fell but now
they mean something very different the
situation has been radicalized
houses on fire isn't the solution but
it's a sign of discontent and the
politicians need to be reminded of what
people think PES Saxony systematically
denied and hidden a problem with
right-wing extremism
many say conservatives and government
here for the last 25 years have done
just that
others disagree yeah the people here are
not right-wing extremists or Nazis
they're concerned citizens
so our faint-hearted politicians who bow
to the voting power wielded by
right-wing parties to blame what has
gone wrong in Saxony
economist kena how would you answer that
question when it comes to state
politicians the state premier said this
week that he doesn't see any reason to
fault himself or his administration over
the latest incidents that he feels that
he has continuously fulfilled his
responsibility do you think he's right
same procedure as every year I mean
that's what I really expected in that's
the most saddest part of that I mean it
seems like we haven't learned anything
from the National Socialist underground
you know like the murder in Syria so
which has been primarily let's just
remind our viewers those that was the
group that underground for over 10 years
committed murders against people of a
migrant matron background with impunity
basically police not doing anything to
investigate the murders for a long long
time exactly and as I heard that the
police is going to investigate against
the refugees who were in the bus for
having provoked the hate mongers you
know I immediately thought of the NS o
mother serious because that was the time
when people who were killed primarily
the family members were the suspects so
the police and all the institutions were
working you know or focusing primarily
on the victims rather than on the
perpetrators of so I think we have an
institutional problem so the
institutions need to be really
scrutinized and then also politics etc
so what we have here is the problem that
a denial of the reality and then the
second thing is that we have established
hate mongers especially in in in parties
which have been more or less established
like the AFD alternative for Germany IRT
and all these parties hasn't been
confronted with with the issues so more
or less Allen has been saying that they
have been jumping from issue to issue on
the one side it's very difficult to
confront all these established hate
mongers and politicians because most of
them
simply fighting against democracy not
against certain issues because it was
Islam that it was the Euro no it is the
refugees so whatever topic you have it
is against this Democratic state it's
wholly confront anti-democratic
movements by and with Democratic issues
and arguments in front of mark in your
research in Saxony what were the
conclusions that you drew about the
complicity or responsibility of local
officials the fact is you say in your
opening statement the government of the
state has not understood that fighting
xenophobia is a major task but that
extends all the way to prosecutors in
courts they have hardly been falling
over themselves to charge and try
perpetrators of xenophobic incidents
over the past year well they have in
fact there there was an investigation
and the sex the people in secondly are
quite proud that they have a center of
they call it operative defense center or
something like that where they actually
went after some of the incidents but
still when I talk to the Interior
Minister for example and asked him so
why is it always Saxony and he said well
we have to analyze that now and you ask
yourself why do they start to analyze
now I mean this is a problem for a
number of years now and we had those big
numbers in Saxony and over such a long
time and still they lack proper strategy
and a plan and the commitment to say
this is our major task we have to tackle
this problem that's at the very core of
our policies and that's what I'm missing
there on the political level and then
when we talk about the state premiere
and when we talk about language I mean
he was the one who said Islam doesn't
belong to Saxony and of course these are
statements that are part of a certain
climate that doesn't help and he was
also the state premier who didn't go to
pegida and say I am against this who he
was at the beginning talking about well
it's concerned citizens we have to talk
to them for a long time and and he also
doesn't take notice that in his own
constituency which
bouton there are 34 initiatives that are
actually opposing this refugee shelter
so there are aspects that are really not
satisfying when you look at the
governmental side and in Saxony and it's
also peculiarity in sexy that you had a
government of the Conservatives for 25
years and this is one of the topics that
we have mentioned before I mean of
course it's not a fault of the CDU I
don't want to say that I want to judge
there but it is a special situation if
one party can govern for 25 years it has
a certain feeling to the people and it
creates a certain climate one of the
state premiers was called King Kurt but
even the the recent settlement on the
head mongers he said there are not
humans there are criminals
you cannot dehumanize these people
because it is the problem is there so
it's not you know it doesn't happen it's
not something like a UFO who came there
and then did all these protests but it
is people from Saxony and you have to
deal with these people and he cannot be
humanized these people although I don't
want to weigh every word but if he says
he sent humans these are criminals
then you criminalize and then you
exclude these really mainstream ideology
and it is a mainstream ideology which
you need to tackle in fact that
statement was made shortly after these
incidents when Saxony's politicians
began to realize that possibly this was
a wake-up call they have all been
calling for saxon citizens to stand up
now against xenophobia saying their
state should not be identified with the
angriest of its citizens let's take a
listen
what can concealed renard born
right-wing comes from the situation they
grow up in and their social environment
this probably may haven't addressed this
problem in Saxony for 25 years people
acted like right-wing extremism didn't
exist is that that's why we're really
pushing at the moment to get the people
in the silent majority which I'm
convinced is there like to take a
clearer more conspicuous stand
opposition yield people from all over
the world who've come to our city and
feel totally at home in this beautiful
city who like working and living here
are suddenly afraid to go out on the
street Isaac in imposing post know
there's an idiom in German that's been
quoted quite a lot recently it goes like
this
a fish stinks from the head if we take
that idiom and look at Saxony where
would you say the buck stops in terms of
responsibility for the atmosphere that
has been conducive for this violence is
it the local government or does it go
all the way to the federal interior
ministry perhaps even to the Bavarian
sister party of the Chancellor's
Christian Democrats well no I mean yeah
fish stinks from the head but that's
that's exactly the saying that's
actually been used against democracy
because things are going wrong here and
there you know and then people say well
it's the government's fault I don't buy
that you know in Saxony they could have
done a whole lot more local government
could have done a whole lot more
the point is friends take teachers and
the 90% of people teaching in Saxony
school today school today we're teaching
in communist schools and they set up
this whole authoritarian set up and
these are things that haven't beat have
you actually talked you know there's
this this sort of loose talk about oh
well in the old days we had the commerce
regime now we have the capitalist regime
and it's you know and that's the kind of
loose talk which came from from the
left-wing which is now infiltrated into
the right-wing if this that's what I'm
getting at
mccuddin miss Gaynor you said in your
opening statement that politicians are
definitely creating the climate would
you even list national politicians among
those who are making mob rule in Saxony
possible yes not not with intention but
all these arguments has been in fact
encouraging those people on the right
side you know if you talk about the rule
of injustice then then you are
addressing politics of welcoming and
openness etc as something in jest
so whatever you do against that seems
like just that was a statement made by
the head of the Chancellor's sister
party the Christian social Union horse
say over looking to win populist support
there from being funded Marc people in
Saxony are now saying you know what this
could wind up being bad for our economy
international firms may leave tourists
may not come will that be enough of a
wake-up call to get the mob under
control maybe I think they have realized
that they have a problem now maybe this
was for the first time a strong federal
reaction but it has to be a bigger
reaction it's still not enough and I'm
afraid something II worse has to happen
before people actually wake up and and
really stand up and grasp this problem
as it is as the major problem for them
mob rule in Saxony that's been this
week's quadriga and if you would like to
see more of the mayor of dresden we are
running an interview with him in our
programs on sunday so check that out
thanks for being with us see you soon